the number of homeless people in europe is estimated at more or less 3 million
every night more than 400,000 people
sleep on our streets it is a
tangible daily problem that we
face in our cities and which
challenges us the causes of this problem
are multiple  and complex but it is
established that the parameters of the
housing markets as well as housing policies
have a
considerable impact iraq on homelessness which is
a form of extreme exclusion and which
particularly affects vulnerable groups in
particular people with
disabilities and  migrants highly nana
same lady by klose icade europa when
the well like itunes belgrade refuses
to buy bottom line is that a
group of small format 10 1 2 european
like here in aveyron and
commission groups now have european
like italy
honda klaus heitz maracana stadium beta au
bard ap
bofa draft loneliness
european commission is just a pretty
clumsy guy  oite schiste 2007 and objective because
she forgets villa promote a framework
a jacket eeyou
social impact investors at scea if they wanted that
program or locality of you you were
first integral to a strategy
regional national local and
governors to monitor  prioritizing will
solve
22.6 align politics whoever
practices this area he would like to ploughed
national strategic framework
sectoral collaborators integrated into
our local politics the scl a
final comic roles lichsteiner
mosquitoes omissions that cannot be
governed by the oica and ford libdems
film preventively in the repechage in
remained how is it possible that on the one
hand the right to housing is mentioned
in the European pillar of
social rights in the charter of
fundamental rights and that on the other hand the
member states which invest in
social housing are sanctioned by the
commission  European
under the pretext that it is necessary would be the
competition  from the sacrosanct market,
commissioner, housing
is not a commodity
if you agree with me, but
then prove it and get
public investment in social housing out
of the 3% rule
because in order to be able to live to be
able  dream you have to know where to sleep
[Music]
no
get delivered